من الواضح أننا في نقطة
خلاف حاول العديد من الأشخاص
تسييس هذا الأمر ، لكنك تسمعه
من فم الحصان ،
فهذا ليس سياسيًا ، بل هو
اقتصادي بحت استنادًا إلى خبرة 40 أو
50 عامًا من رسم الخرائط في الاتجاهات التي نقوم بها  عدم
الانخراط في سياسة أي شخص
نشاركه ببساطة كموازن
ومثبت للاقتصاد من خلال
سوق الطاقة كما فعلنا تاريخيًا ،
دعني أقدم كحجة مضادة لمنظور
البيت الأبيض الذي اتهمه البيت الأبيض السعودية بالانحياز إليه
مع روسيا هي المملكة المنحازة
لروسيا ، فأنت تعلم أن المملكة لديها
سياسة التعامل مع الجميع في جميع
المجالات ممن نتفق معهم وأولئك الذين
لا نتفق
مع العلاقة التي كانت لدينا مع روسيا
هو ما سمح لنا
بإطلاق سراح أسرى الحرب للأمريكيين
خمسة بريطانيين حلو واحد ومجموعة مختارة
من البلدان الأخرى نرى دورنا
كوسيط ومحاور لقد
دعمنا أوكرانيا
إنسانيًا قدمنا ​​أكثر من 400 مليون  توقفنا
مع أوكرانيا وبولندا لمنح 10
ملايين للسماح للاجئين الذين
كانوا يخرجون من أوكرانيا
وينتقلون إلى بولندا بالهبوط الآمن ،
وهذا ما نفعله وهذه قيمة
مشاركتنا هي انحيازنا لروسيا
ولم تحدثت شخصيًا إلى
الإدارة حول هذا ما هي
فكرة الاتصال بشكل منتظم جدًا
مع الإدارة وبصراحة إنها
إدارة
أحترمها بشدة لم يكن لدي سوى
التواصل الأكثر كرمًا ومباشرًا كما
ينبغي لنا أن هذه هي الطريقة التي يتواصل بها الشركاء
مع بعضهم البعض وبالمناسبة لا بأس
بذلك  لا أوافق ، لقد اختلفنا في
الماضي واتفقنا في الماضي ولكن
الشيء المهم هو الاعتراف
بقيمة هذه العلاقة التي يمكن للمملكة أن تفعلها
بدون علاقة
مع واشنطن
بيكي ، لا يمكن للعالم الاستغناء عن
علاقة مع الولايات المتحدة  أمريكا
ليس لديهم شك في أن الولايات المتحدة هي
الولايات المتحدة لمدة 80 عامًا ، فقد كانت
حليفنا الاستراتيجي لمدة ثماني سنوات
لقد كنت شريكًا لنا ، كما تعلم ، أسمع
الكثير من الناس يتحدثون عن الإصلاح أو
يراجعون العلاقة مع
المملكة وأعتقد في الواقع أن هذا
أمر إيجابي ، هذه المملكة ليست
المملكة التي كانت عليها قبل خمس سنوات ، إنها
ليست المملكة بل كانت 10  منذ سنوات ،
لم يعد كل جزء من التحليل موجودًا
ذا صلة ، فنحن شباب
لدينا قيادة شابة ،
ولدينا طموح وهدف للتفاعل
مع العالم بطريقة لم نقم بها من
قبل قبل أن تكون غريباً عن مبنى الكابيتول الأمريكي.
أمضيت سنوات هناك عندما
كان والدك هو السفير الأمير باندا آنذاك ،
فكيف كان الوقت الذي قضيته في واشنطن عندما
كنت شابًا يخبرنا عمن تعيش الآن
في واشنطن العاصمة وخاصة
في الدوائر الدبلوماسية وبعد أن كنا
هناك لمدة 23 عامًا منذ أن كنت في السابعة من
عمري  إلى 30.
أنت منغمس في شيء
لا تعرفه حتى أنه يحدث للأشخاص
الذين أحاطوا بنا ، والمحادثات التي
استمعنا إليها إلى الأشياء التي شملنا بها والدي
في ذلك الوقت  بصراحة
لم أقدّر أنني كنت أشاهد
التاريخ وهو يحدث وهذا مهم جدًا
عندما تتعامل مع
علاقة الولايات المتحدة في
المملكة إذا لم تضعها في سياقها في
التاريخ فلن تفهم سبب
أهمية أن نظل أقوياء
وثابت وهادئ في هذه
الشراكة التي استمرت 80 عامًا والثمانين عامًا
القادمة يمكن أن تكون رائعة إذا
سمحنا بذلك ، هل يمكنك حقًا أن تكون أكثر تفاؤلاً
بشأن تحالف أكثر فاعلية
للمضي قدمًا
يمكنني بيكي لأن
هناك أشياء
في الرؤية  2030 أن المملكة
استثمرت فيها وأشعر أن العالم لا
يرى رقم واحد ، نعم نحن أحد
أكبر منتجي النفط في العالم ،
لكن المملكة تعيد صياغة نفسها لتكون
واحدة من أكبر منتجي الطاقة
، وضعنا مليارات الدولارات  في
الاستثمارات في مصادر الطاقة المتجددة والرياح الشمسية ،
أي شيء يمكن أن تتخيله ،
فنحن نراهن على سبب وجود بيكي
لأن المملكة ضمن رؤية 2030 لديها
مبادرة تسمى المبادرة الخضراء
السعودية  iative التي هي هديتنا
للأجيال القادمة ليس فقط لبلدنا
ولكن للعالم ونحن نفعل ذلك في
توازن سوق النفط لأنه
لا يمكنك الابتعاد عن أحدهما حتى يصبح
الآخر جاهزًا وبالمناسبة
التزامنا هو أن يكون لدينا  تمت تلبية 50 من احتياجات الطاقة المحلية لدينا
بواسطة مصادر الطاقة المتجددة بحلول
نهاية هذا العقد وليس 50 عامًا من
الآن تلك السردية التي تقول هنا في
رؤية المملكة 2030 التي تنسجم النجاح مع
الاستدامة قد قوبلت ببعض
الشكوك ، وهذا صحيح بما يكفي
لأن الأمر يستغرق وقتًا  بناء هذه
الأشياء ، يستغرق الأمر وقتًا للتحول ، يستغرق الأمر
وقتًا للإصلاح ، تعلم أن الكثير من
الأشخاص يتحدثون معي عنه ، هل
الإصلاحات صحيحة ، هل هي صحيحة ، يجب
أن أخبرك بصراحة بيكي ، لقد غادرت
الولايات المتحدة في عام 2005 حيث كانوا
لا يزالون  أتجادل حول السيطرة على السلاح
وحقوق الإجهاض والرعاية الصحية ، وقد عدت
في عام 2019 إلى نفس
المحادثة وغادرت مملكة حيث شهدنا خلال خمس
سنوات تغييرًا أكثر مما
كان لدينا في 80 عامًا حيث  تحتل حقوق المرأة موقع
الصدارة حيث يحتل إدراج الإناث
الصدارة وقد انتهينا من ذلك ، لقد حددنا
عام 2030 ليكون نقطة نرغب
في تحقيق أقصى قدر من إنجازها ولكن خمن ما
سيحدث في عام 2030. الجولة التالية من
التغيير لها  سيحدث لأن الجيل التالي
يأتي ويقول شكرًا لك ،
ولكن هذه هي احتياجاتي ، نحن ببساطة
نجعل أنفسنا محاصرين مع
العالم وعليك أن تمنحنا الوقت لأن
التحول لا يحدث في يوم واحد
كان لدى الولايات المتحدة 200  رحلة عام
من التحول كان لدينا 80. نحن
أشخاص مختلفون في مكان مختلف
وسنصل إلى هناك لأننا
نؤمن بنفس الشيء الذي نؤمن به
في الإحساس بالفرصة
لشعبنا ونحن فخورون جدًا به  التغييرات التي
حدثت